Leslie I want to sit remember we can
work out the area of a triangle and with
the entry right so two triangles we can
work out the area triangle using the
formula that we all appeal to to get
this number this one has been any
students right that point minute is area
equals by the way do you remember why
it's hot base times like why don't like
the third or fantastic how do you
remember from what we actually looked at
this every tribe every triangle can be
placed inside a rectangle that is
exactly doublet area okay well you only
want one half of that because it's
tribal but that's where the fraction
culture there's just a little tiny
problem with this formula it's that you
always need to have what you guys just
worked out you always need to have the
base and you don't just think anyone is
a specific height you need its the
perpendicular height okay so you either
need like a right angle triangle that's
perpendicular or if I give you odds with
you actually if you get a triangle that
it's not right angles
for instance if over here and 37 or
something like this okay if there's no
right angles in here that's not enough
you can't work out that area yet you
need more information what lengths would
you like to get in order for me to
calculate the area
let me do it again yeah I don't label
this at all so from the tip is accurate
enough and if I go straight to the
bottom so long as it's a right angled
right does anyone know by the way that
dotted line has a special name starts
with a we usually use the same way when
we're talking about how high something
is in the air like a mountain or a plane
and
so in order to use this you need an
altitude however we've just shown even
when you don't have all the information
Creek can help you so today we're going
to develop a new way to find the area of
triangle and we'll be able to find the
area of any triangle not just the ones
where we have an altitude so please do
me a favor underneath this diet on this
heading I want you to draw our nice big
triangle that's not as your drawing and
he's my nan right angle triangle not
just a tiny blue night you'll see this
time because I want to talk about in
detail I've labeled all of the vertices
vertices are usually labeled with
capital letters and I've also labeled
all of the legs usually legs are may
labeled without Lois
okay in addition to and this is
important don't draw this because I'm
gonna rub off in a second I named the
vertices and the lengths in a way that's
not random I've done them in relation to
each other so can anyone see how do I
know yeah okay so I'm doing opposites so
for example little a is opposite being a
little C is opposite big C etc okay
don't draw the hell to your diagram
because I'm going to get rid of that in
a second we're gonna put other
constructions but just remember it
because it's important all right now
this is not right angle so therefore
just like I show over here what I'm sort
of going to need to get is the height of
this training I'm gonna put in an
altitude in a second I don't know what
the altitude is but I'm going to find
out so down
I'm gonna label my altitude so this
altitude here is called H because it
does give me the height I shouldn't let
alone without a writing okay okay when
you have a look at this because I have
put in an altitude I have formed some
right-angled triangles and write a word
flavors are what you can use to take
advantage of all in this trade stuff
okay so have a look have a look how
could I find what this is based on all
the rest of the information around me
okay
I'm gonna focus your attention by
thinking about one of the angles in
particular you actually could pick any
angle you want that's one of the nice
things about this but just for the sake
of consistency if I knew what the size
of this angle was I'm gonna call it
capital C because that's where it's at
if I knew the size of C and I also know
this this length over here a can you see
and this is worth added your decorator
can you see that both of these guys as
well as the length that you want they
all exist in the same writer who trained
will do you see it
can we label it in it goes like this
there's beside there there's a and I
don't know what this bottom like this
but I actually don't care all right
so have a look look at the red triangle
now how can I use my trick stuff to find
learn H and the answer is which side
right cuz look so funky right from this
end or the side you want is opposite and
the side you know is the hypotenuse so I
would say sine of this angle that I'm
working at see it is equal to opposite
by hypotenuse
okay so that's okay okay
so if all I want about the only one if
all I want is the altitude I'm just
going to multiply both sides by hey hey
and that will leave the hid third okay
so it's going to be on its own I'll put
it over on the left as well so H is a
times sine C okay now these are all
letters at the moment because I don't
know what any of these are but I can
plug in the numbers as soon as I know
them for a specific triangle okay I'm
almost there
now I know what the height is right so
therefore I can come back to my original
way of using the area of a triangle
right so if H is this therefore the area
is 1/2 times the base which is still be
down the bottom here times the height
well this is the height right
so can you see this formula now doesn't
require a CH in aluminum I could rub a
page and I could use this egg this B and
this angle in here it's nice to writer
in a bit of a more complicated
coordinated way so the way that you will
find on your formula sheet is this the
area of a triangle is half a B sciency
it's got a nice rigid if you go to your
formula sheet it's on the side it's on
the last page I believe so that's on the
side with two pages on it and you'll
find it sort of in the middle there on
the left column of the third page okay
err triangle half a B sine C put the big
box around that because that's a really
useful result it means I'm no longer
reliant on having the altitude the
perpendicular height somewhere so long
as I know two sides and an angle I'm
done as in do I use this one or do I use
that one is that the question you're
asking
ah oh yeah you couldn't have sink right
into my final point any better remember
I said to you when we drew this thing I
said excuse me I said pay attention to
where the sides are right remember I
said this a is opposite name this Bay's
opposite me etc okay excuse me
so therefore if you've got a and B pick
any two sides of the triangle you like
do you see that angle C must be the
angle that's in between them
do you see that if this is M be the last
side is see if you go opposite that you
always find yourself between a and B
okay I'm you can joy of self a new
triangle just to prove that to yourself
find like some brand
over here suppose I knew these two sides
okay that makes this side the silly the
boot side right do you agree with that
which means which angle is the C angle
it's this one up in here right we have a
fancy name for that we call it and this
is worth actually labeling onto your
diagram we call that the included angle
because we all know what it's like when
you've got two friends in there watching
something on their phone and they've got
their two headphones and then you're
over there on the edge and you're
excluded well this is the included angle
and it's right between them I've got to
use that one all right so when you're
doing hot baby sign see these can be in
two sides you're like but this guy has
to be has to be the angle in between
them and sometimes a more difficult
question we purposely give you the other
angles even though you don't need them
because what they're trying to do is
work out do you know can you tell the
difference between the ones that matter
and the ones that don't okay does that
make sense
okay determine agree make any questions
about this and how to use it you've got
it down your formula sheet so you never
have to remember this but to be honest
between the students and extension ones
they all have to learn this as well I
found this one of the easiest ones to
memorize it kinda has a nice sort of
rolls off the tongue half baby side see
it arrived